สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะ
และขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่
ห้องเรียน comprehensible ไทยห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาติค่ะค่ะวันนี้ก็มาเจอ
กันอีกแล้วครูชิตามนัดใช่มั้ยคะใช่เรามี
นัดกันอืนะเรามีนัดมาจากเจอกันในวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้ก็วันพุธสิคะครูบีวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันพุธที่ 6 ค่ะอ่าเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมค่ะอ่าเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ค่ะค่ะแล้วปี
พุทธศักราชเหรอคะปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะครูบีนะคะวันนี้เรา 2 คนก็มาพบ
กันในวันพุธอืมวันพุธนะวันนี้วันพุธนะครู
ชิใส่เสื้อเนี่ยสีเขียวตรงกับวันพุธมั้ย
คะหรือว่าสีฟ้าคะเนี่ยเสื้อกูชิตรงค่ะสี
เขียวค่ะ
อืแต่ครูบีดูแล้วเนี่ยมันเป็นสีฟ้านะคะสี
ฟ้าเหรอคะเพราะว่าซูมไฟที่ซูมเนี่ยวีดีโอ
ซูมเนี่ยบางบางทีเนี่ยใส่สีเขียวเป็นสี
ฟ้าอ๋อนี่ๆๆครูชิจะให้ดูของครูชิเนี่ยมี
ป้ายนี่ค่ะอันเนี้ยสีฟ้าอือันเนี้ยสี
เขียวฟ้าเขียวเขียวเนาะอือหือก็เป็นสี
เขียวนะคะใช่ค่ะอ่าตรงกับวันใส่เสื้อสี
ตรงกับวันแล้ววันนี้ครูชินัดครูบีมาเนี่ย
จะมามาเล่าอะไรให้ฟังคะคุยเรื่องอะไรคะโห
ครูชี้เนี่ยรู้สึกว่าบางทีเนี่ยก็นึกแล้ว
ก็คิดย้อนเออเนาะพอเวลาเราอายุมากขึ้นมาก
ขึ้นมากขึ้นทำไมชอบคิดเหมือนกับที่ผ่านมา
แล้วทำไมไม่คิดถึงวันข้างหน้าคะอืเ้าก็
ถ้าเราอายุมากขึ้นเนี่ยเราก็จะชอบคิดย้อน
กลับไปตอนเป็นเด็กๆไงครูชิเพราะว่าอายุ
มากขึ้นมากขึ้นน่ะก็คิดมากๆนะเดี๋ยวก็
โอ๊ยปวดหลังสุขภาพไม่แข็งแรงไม่สบายแต่
ตอนที่เราเป็นเด็กๆเนี่ยไม่ต้องคิดอะไร
ใช่มั้ย 3 ขวบ 4 ขวบ 5 ขวบโอ้โหกินๆนอนๆ
สบายมันก็เลยทำให้บางทีเนี่ยครูบี่ครูชิ
ดูทีวีดูข่าวใช่มั้ยเออแต่ไม่ใช่ข่าวจาก
บางกอกโพส The เนชไม่ใช่ข่าวเอ่อของเอ่อ
ของคนไทยทั่วๆไปเเรียกว่าข่าวชาวบ้าน
อืข่าวที่คนไทยเนี่ยดูใช่มั้ยอย่างตื่น
เช้ามาเปิดทีวีเปิดทีวีแล้วก็ดูข่าวช่อง 3
ช่อง 7 อ่าใช่นะข่าวชาวบ้านก็เช่นข่าวที่
แบบคนขับรถแล้วก็ชนกันแล้วก็ตายหรือว่า
พ่อแม่เนี่ยมีลูกแล้วลูกเนี่ยก็ตีพ่อแม่
ไปโรงพยาบาลอันนี้เราเรียกว่าข่าวชาวบ้าน
อืทีเนี้ยครูชิก็จะเห็นว่าตอนเนี้ยข่าว
เนี่ยจะเหมือนกับคนเราเนี่ยเห็นใครทำอะไร
แล้วก็อยากจะทำตามไงอืมเห็นคนเนี้ยเปิด
ร้านขายอะไรนะเอ่อน้ำลำไยสดอุ๊ยขายดีก็
เลยทำตามบ้างก็เอาอน้ำลำไยสดมาขายเหมือนๆ
เค้าไปอยู่ใกล้ๆกันแล้วก็ขายเหมือนๆกัน
อ๋อเหมือนครูบีเคยเห็นมีผู้ชายเนี่ยเขา
ทอดลูกชิ้นขายลูกชิ้นหมูนะคะลูกชิ้นที่
เสียบไม้เป็นก้อนกลมๆเนาะแล้วก็เอาไปทอด
แล้วก็อืครูบีชอบกินค่ะก็มีคนเนี่ยเห็น
ว่าผู้ชายคนเนี้ยขายลูกชิ้นทอดเนี่ยอูมี
เงินอ่ามีลูกค้ามากๆเก็เลยมาเปิดร้านใกล้
ๆแล้วก็ขายลูกชิ้นเหมือนกันใช่ครูชี้ก็
เลยนึกถึงว่าตอนเด็กๆอ่ะค่ะครูชี้เนี่ย
ได้ยินเอ่อคุณครูเนี่ยเล่านิทานเรื่องนึง
ให้ฟังค่ะครูบีโหตอนเด็กๆเนี่ยงั้นครูชิ
ต้องย้อนกลับไปแล้วค่ะอ่า 20 ปีที่แล้ว
ใช่มั้ยคะ 20 ปีที่แล้วตอนครูชิเป็นเด็กๆ
อายุประมาณเท่าไหร่ครูชิตอนที่เราเรียน
โรงเรียนอนุบาลก็อยู่เอ่อต้องบอกนะว่า
อายุแบบ 3 ขวบ 4 ขวบ 5 ขวบอันนี้อยู่
อนุบาล 1  2  3 อันเนี้ยครูอ่ะจะสอนด้วย
การเล่านิทานให้ฟังอ๋อถ้าพูดถึงนิทาน
เนี่ยครูบีก็รู้จักนะเพราะว่าตอนครูบี
เด็กๆคุณครูที่โรงเรียนก็จะเล่านิทาน
ซินเดอเรลล่าสโนวไวท์
แล้วก็มีเด็นี้ทานฝรั่งอ่ะเด็กๆเลี้ยงแกะ
อ่ะแเด็กชอบโกหกแล้วก็เรื่องอะไรนะ
พิน็อกคิโอ
โกหกแล้วก็จมูกใหญ่ใช่มั้ยเออจมูกยาวๆอ่ะ
โไม่รู้จักเหรอคะนิทาน
ฝรั่งก็คูชิ 20 ปี 30 ปีที่แล้วไงก็เลย
ไม่รู้
จักคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยตอนูชิเด็กๆเนี่ยครู
ก็ชอบเล่านิทานแบบคนไทยนะอ๋อนิานแบบคน
ไทยกใช่เกี่ยวกับอะไรคพูดถึงเทวดาค่ะโอ้
คนไทยเนี่ยก็นะทุกคนเนี่ยชอบคิดว่ามี
เทวดาแเทวดาหน้าตาเป็นยังไง
อ้อเทวดาไเทวดาเนี่ยก็ต้องหล่อค่ะนัก
เรียนบอกว่ามาประเทศไทยจะนึกถึงเทวดาต้อง
ไปวัด
ค่ะที่วัดที่ฝาผนังของวัดค่ะจะมีเทวดาพนม
มืออืใช่นะคะแล้วก็อันเนี้ย
ค่ะคนไทยอ่ะมีความเชื่อนะอก็คิดทุกที่
เนี่ยมีเทวดาค่ะอืนะนี่ค่ะูชิ
เทวดาจริงๆเทวดาเนี่ยเราจะคิดถึงอู้อยู่
บนท้องฟ้าใช่ค่ะอยู่บนสวรรค์เนาะเราต้อง
มองไปที่ท้องฟ้าอ่าแต่ครูชิบอกเทวดามีทุก
ที่เดี๋ยวดูครูชิวาดรูปนะคะอยู่บนท้องฟ้า
ออืมีเทวดาที่แบบให้ฝนอืมใช่มั้ยเทวดาที่
ให้ฝนค่ะนะคะเทวดาที่อยู่ที่ต้นไม้อ่า
เหมือนที่ครูิให้ดูเนาะเมื่อกี้อันนี้
เป็นเทวดาต้ไม้ใหญ่ๆอเทวดาที่อยู่ที่ต้น
ไม้ใช่อที่ต้นไม้ก็มีเทวดามีค่ะเรามีความ
เชื่อเกี่ยวกับเอ่อต้นไม้แม่น้ำภูเขานะฮะ
อจะมีเทวดานะคะแล้วก็ที่ต้นไม้เค่ะูบีค่ะ
ต้นไม้ก็มีเทวดาค่ะอยู่อ
อือเทวดาเอยู่ทุกที่จริงๆนะอ่าแบบคนไทยนะ
คะแบบความเชื่อคนไทยเนาะอืใช่ค่ะอทำไมคน
ไทยถึงไหว้ต้นไม้เข้าใจแล้วค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ต้น
ไม้ใช่เพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยคนไทยเนี่ยอยาก
จะทำอะไรกับอยากบางทีอ่ะครูบีไปไปไป
เที่ยวแล้วก็ขับรถเนี่ยข้างทางมีแต่ต้น
ไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้อ่ะไม่มีปั๊มน้ำมัน
ไม่มีห้องน้ำผู้ชายสบายไงผู้ชายก็จะแบบขอ
โทษต้นไม้ก่อนนะแล้ว
ก็อยู่ข้างๆทางใช่มยอันนี้ต้องคนไทยต้อง
ขอโทษก่อนนะก่อนที่จะจะจะฉี่นะคะก็เช่น
เดียวกันค่ะที่ต้นไม้เนี่ยมีเทวดาแล้ว
เรื่องเนี้ยเขาก็เล่าถึงผู้ชายคนนึงค่ะ
เป็นผู้ชายใช่มั้ยแล้วผู้ชายคนเนี้ยนะคะ
มีอาชีพทำอะไรคะตัดฟืนนะคะอืเค้าก็จะอ่า
นี่ค่ะอาชีพตัดฟืนเหรอูชิถ้าอาชีพตัดฟืน
เนี่ยมันก็ต้องแบบโอ้โหแบกขวานนะคะใช่ใช่
มยเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ได้มี
เครื่องมือที่เป็นแบบเทคโนโลยีเนาะครูชิ
ไม่มีเลื่อยไฟ
ฟ้าถูกค่ะเราต้องมีขวานแล้วก็แบกไปค่ะอืม
ใช่ผู้ชายคนเนี้ยก็มีอาชีพตัดฟืนไงตัดต้น
ไม้แล้วก็มาทำฟืนน่ะเมื่อก่อนเราไม่มีไฟ
ฟ้านะค่ะเราก็ใช้ฟืนแบบนี้ค่ะตัดต้นไม้
ให้เป็นฟืน
อืมใช่มั้ยโอใช่นะแบบนี้นะแล้วก็เอาไปขาย
อนี้อต้นไม้ใหญ่หน่อยเนาอ่าอันนี้น่าจะ
เอาไปทำฟืนแล้วก็เอาไปเผาถ่านด้วยนะ
คะตัดต้นไม้นะคะอ่าแต่ว่าต้องใช้ขวานไง
ูชิเห็นมยที่มือเา้าเนี่ยจะมีขวานใช่ค่ะ
ทีนี้ผู้ชายคนเนี้ยค่ะก็ไปตัดต้นไม้ต้น
ไม้เนี่ยก็อยู่ใกล้ๆแม่น้ำค่ะอือืใกล้ๆ
แม่น้ำนะค่ะอยู่ใกล้แม่น้ำผู้ชายคนเนี้ย
ตัดตัดต้นไม้ตัดไปตัดมาเนี่ยขวานค่ะครูบี
เกิดอะไรขึ้นคะขวานเนี่ยหลุดออกจากมือนะ
คะกำลังแบบจะฟันใช่มยฟันต้นไม้ฟันๆันไป
แล้วมันก็หลุดบึบๆๆๆๆแล้วก็ตกลงไปในน้ำ
ค่ะอืเววตู้มโอ้โหอ่าทำยังไงงอ่ะตัดต้น
ไม้ยังไม่เสร็จใช่มั้ยูชิยังไม่เสร็จแล้ว
ขวานก็ตกลงไปในน้ำแล้วอ่ะโอผู้ชายคนนี้ก็
มีขวานอันเดียวออแล้วจะทำยังไงล่ะทำถ้า
ไม่มีขวานเนี่ยก็ผ่าฟืนไม่ได้ขายไม่ได้ก็
ไม่มีเงินนะอืมผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ร้องไห้แบบ
เสียใจโอ๊ยขวานไปแล้วว่ายน้ำก็ไม่เป็นใช่
มั้ยถ้าวยน้ำเป็นก็อาจจะลงไปแล้วก็งมดำ
ใช่มั้ยดำลงไปแล้วก็ไปหาหาหาหาขวานอืแต่
เขาว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นเาก็เลยนั่งอยู่ใกล้ๆ
แม่น้ำแล้วก็ร้องไห้อือ่าอ้าวคือขวาน
เนี่ยตกลงไปในแม่น้ำถ้าว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นก็
กระโดดลงไปงมขวานไม่ได้เนาะไม่ได้ไงก็เลย
ได้แต่ร้องไห้อเทวดาาต้นไม้หรือเราเรียก
ว่าลุขเทวดานะคะก็ออกมาค่ะเพราะสงสารได้
ยินเสียงผู้ชายคนเนี้ยร้องไห้นานแล้วไม่
ยอมกลับบ้านนะร้องไห้ร้องไห้ก็เลยแบบว่า
เทวดาก็เลยออกมาแล้วก็ถามว่าเจ้าร้องไห้
ทำไม
อือ่าเทวดาเนี่ยามผายอใช่ค่ะว่าเอ้าเจ้า
เนี่ยมานั่งร้องไห้อยู่ตรงเนี้ยทำไมเหรอ
อืผู้ชายที่ร้องไห้ก็บอกเขวานขวานของเรา
อ่ะที่ตัดต้นไม้อ่ะมันตกลงไปในน้ำแล้วเรา
ก็ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นเราก็ไม่สามารถดำลงไปหา
ขวานได้อ๋อมันมีคือขวานหนึ่งเท่านั้นอืก็
คือตกลงไปแบบนี้ใช่มยูชิใช่ค่ะ
อืมแล้วเทวดาว่ายังไงอ่ะแล้วเทวดาก็เลย
อาสาอาสาก็คือว่าช่วยช่วยโดยที่ไม่คิด
อะไรนะไม่เอาอะไรเลยนะก็คิดอยากจะช่วย
เท่านั้นก็เลยลงไปดำน้ำลงไปแล้วก็เอาขวาน
มาให้แต่พอดำน้ำลงไปเนี่ยเทวดาก็คิดนะเอ๊
เราช่วยผู้ชายคนเนี้ยผู้ชายคนนี้เป็นคนดี
หรือคนคนไม่ดีอืมนะเทวดาก็เลยอยากเช็คนะ
ค่ะอ๋ออยากเช็คว่าผู้ชายคนเนี้ยเป็นคนดี
หรือไม่ดีอ้าวแล้วเทวดาจะเช็คยังไงอ่ะูชิ
เทวดาก็เลยเอาขวานขึ้นมาที่นี่แต่ขวาน
เนี้ยค่ะเทวดาลองใจเอาขวานทองค่ะครูบี
โอโหทองกำลังแพงเลยนะ
ฮโอ้โห
เทวดาอันนี้เทวดาฝรั่งนะขวานทองแบบริง
โอ้โหเอ้ยแต่ดูผู้ชายทำไมเ้าทำท่าอย่าง
เงี้่ะคะบอกโอ๊ะๆๆขวานทองเนี่ยไม่ใช่ของ
ผมครับไม่ใช่ของผมนะอือ๋อบอกว่าอันเนี้ย
ไม่ใช่ของผมขวานทองมันแพงนะไม่ใช่ของผม
หรอกอผมอืไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เทวดาก็แบบรู้สึกดี
ใจนะโอ้ผู้ชายคนเนี้ยซื่อสัตย์อืนะคะไม่
ใช่ของตัวเองก็ไม่เอานะแม้นแต่เป็นทองอืม
เออจริงครูชิเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นทองขวานทอง
เมื่อกี้ใครๆก็อยากได้ใช่มั้ยใครเห็นก็ตา
โตค่ะ
อืมอยากได้ไงขอบคุณ
ค่ะถ้าเป็นครูชิกับกับครูบีเนี่ยอ๋อใช่ๆ
อันนี้แหละขวานของข้าใช่มั้ยโอไม่ซื่อ
สัตย์นะอ้าเหรอเทวดาก็เลยคิดโอ้ผู้ชายคน
นี้ซื่อสัตย์แต่ต้องทดสอบอีกครั้งนึงก็
เลยได้ๆๆขวานนี้ไม่ใช่ของเจ้าข้าจะลงไปดำ
มาใหม่แล้วก็ลงไปแล้วก็ดำเอาขวานมาอันที่
2 เนี่ยเป็นขวานเงินค่ะสีเงินสีขาวแบบ
โอ้โหปิ๊งปังเหมือนแบบเหรียญเงินเลยนะอื
อ้อเป็นขวานเงินนะคะอ่ะขวานเงินก็สี
เหมือนเงินนี่แหละเนาะอ่าแต่ว่าเหมือน
เงินที่เราใช้เนี่ยอ่าอ่ะในรูปก็อาจจะ
เป็นสีแบบนี้นะคะจริงๆเป็นสีเงินอ่า
เหมือนเงินบาทอย่างเงี้เนาะอืใช่ค่ะนะอัน
นี้อันนี้ก็แพงนะแพงทองก็แพงเงินก็แพงอื
แต่คนตัดไม้เนี่ยเห็นขวานแล้วโอ๊ยขวานนี้
ไม่ใช่ใช่ของเรานะอืคนตัดไม้ก็ปฏิเสธอีก
โอท่านท่านเทวดาอันเนี้ยไม่ใช่ขวานของเรา
ครับอืไม่ใช่ขวานของผมครับแล้วเมื่อกี้
ใช่มั้ยครูชิค่ะพอเทวดาหยิบขึ้นมาอันแรก
เนี่ยก็จะเป็นขวานทองก็บอกว่าไม่ใช่อือื
ขวานทองเนี่ยก็ไม่ใช่ของผมอ่าอืขวานเงิน
ก็ไม่ใช่ของผมไม่ใช่ขวานทองก็ไม่ใช่อ้าว
อันไหนเงินเนี่ยกูชิอันนี้เงินมั้งอ่า
ขวานทองขวานเงินเนี่ยไม่ใช่ของผมนะอเทวดา
ก็รู้แล้วว่าอันเนี้ยเป็นคนตรงก็เลยได้ๆๆ
ๆไม่ใช่ของเจ้างั้นเราก็ลงไปดำให้ใหม่ก็
เลยลงไปแล้วก็ดำแล้วก็เอาขวานเหล็กขึ้นมา
ค่ะขวานเหล็กอันเนี้ยแหละที่เป็นของชาย
ตัดฟืนนะคะเป็นฝานเก่าใช่มั้ยใช่อ่าอัน
นี้ฝานเหล็กใช่มั้ยแต่อันนี้ใหม่แต่ของคน
ตัดฟืนนะน่าจะใช้มานานแล้วนะขวานเก่าะนะ
คะพอเห็นขวานเท่านั้นแหละโอหร้องไห้
ขอบคุณเทวดาอันนี้แหละครับของผมขอบคุณ
ท่านลูกเทวดามากๆขอบคุณครับขอบคุณครับ
แล้วก็รับขวานเหล็กของตัวเองไปขวานเก่าๆ
นะเทวดาเห็นว่าผู้ชายตัดฟืนเนี่ยโอ๊ยเป็น
คนดีนะค่ะก็เลยให้ทั้งขวานทองแล้วก็ขวาน
เงินไปด้วยได้ 3 ขวานเลยกลับบ้านอึ้ยจริง
เหรอูชิ
ใช่เทวดาบอกเจ้าเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์มากไม่คิด
จะเอาของที่ไม่ใช่ของตัวเองเพราะฉะนั้น
ขวานทองกับขวานเงินนี้เราให้เจ้าด้วยอ่า
อันนี้ขวานไม้ของตัวเองเนาะขวานที่มัน
เก่านะเทวดาก็ให้ขวานทองแล้วก็ขวานเงิน
สรุปได้กลับไปทั้ง 3 ขวานเลยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
ได้หมด 3 อันเลยคนนี้ก็แบบโอคนตัดฟืนก็ดี
ใจมากเพราะว่าทองกับเงินเนี่ยก็แพงใช่
มั้ยอมีราคาแพงนะคะทองเงินใชพอเได้ขวาน
เงินขวานทองทำให้คนตัดฟืนก็มีฐานะมากขึ้น
มีเงินแล้วไงก็มีฐานะมากขึ้นใช่มั้ยบ้าน
ก็ดูสวยขึ้นเพราะว่ามีเงินออืมบ้านข้างๆ
ค่ะบ้านข้างๆก็เห็น
โอ้ไปรวยอะไรมาเนี่ยทำไมบ้านก็ดูใหญ่ขึ้น
มีเงินมากขึ้นตัดฟืนเนี่ยได้เงินเยอะเหรอ
เค้าบอกว่าเค้าอ่ะไปตัดฟืนเาก็เล่าให้
เพื่อนฟังใช่มั้ยเพื่อนบ้านเพื่อนบ้านก็
ได้ยินใช่มั้ยว่าไปตัดฟืนทำขวานตกเทวดา
เนี่ยมางมขวานให้แล้วก็เลยให้ขวานทองด้วย
ขวานเงินแล้วก็ขวานเหล็กกลับมาตัวเองก็
เลยมีเงินโอ้โหผู้ชายที่เป็นเพื่อนบ้าน
ได้ยินก็แบบโอโหตาโตเลยออฉันรู้แล้วว่า
บ้านนี้รวยเพราะ
อะไรอยากรวยกับเค้าเหมือนกันอ่าทำยังไงคะ
อยากรวยอยากมีขวานเงินขวานทองเหมือนเค้า
อืก็ไปที่เดียวกับเค้าเลยค่ะแล้วก็ไปตัด
ตัดฟืนค่ะตัดไม้อืตัดตัดแล้วก็แกล้งโยน
ขวานทิ้งน้ำตู้มเอ้อแล้วก็นั่งร้องไห้อืม
นะออร้องไห้จนเทวดาขึ้นมาเทวดาก็ออกมาให้
เห็นค่ะแล้วก็มาถามผู้ชายคนนี้เหมือนกัน
อืมร้องไห้ทำไมอ่าผู้ชายคนนี้บอกเทวดาว่า
ยังไงคะบอกว่าเรามาตัดฟืนทำขวานตกน้ำ
เทวดาบอกได้เดี๋ยวเราจะไปงมให้อืมเทวดาก็
ลงไปแล้วก็งมค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ยื่นขวานทองให้
โอหผู้ชายคนนี้เห็นขวานทองนะตาโตแล้วก็
บอกใช่ๆๆขวานนี้ของเรา
อ้าแต่ขวานของเาเนี่ยไม่ใช่ขวานทองไม่ใช่
หรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะเทวดาเนี่ยเห็นว่าผู้ชายคน
เนี้ยไม่ซื่อสัตย์ของที่ไม่ใช่ของตัวเอง
แล้วอยากได้เพราะว่ามันเป็นทองใช่มั้ย
อยากได้ก็เลยโกหกนะโกหกว่าเป็นขวานของตัว
เองอืเทวดาก็เลยหายไปเลยค่ะขวานก็หาย
ไปขวานก็หายเทลเทวดาก็หายเทวดาไม่ช่วย
แล้วอืมเห็นมั้ยไม่ได้ขวานเงินกลับบ้าน
ไม่ได้ขวานทองกลับบ้านแล้วขวานของตัวเอง
ก็โยนทิ้งไปในน้ำแล้วก็อือเสียขวานไปด้วย
โอแล้วขวานเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยก็สำหรับคนเมื่อ
ก่อนต้องเอาไว้ใช้งานเนาะอ่าผู้ชายคนนี้
กลายเป็นว่าไม่ได้อะไรเลยไม่ได้อะไรกลับ
บ้านเลยกลับไปบอกภรรยาภรรยาก็เลยพูดทำไม
ไอคิวไม่ดีทำไมโง่แบบนี้อืเออก็โดนภรรยา
ดายนะอออือันอาจจะทะเลาะกับภรรยานะ
คะเบอกว่านิทานเรื่องเนี้ยอืสอนเราค่ะครู
บีสอนสอนเราเนี่ยให้เป็นยังไงคะสอนยังไง
คะครูชิพอฟังแล้วเนี่ยเราก็รู้รู้ว่าอ๋อ
ผู้ชายที่ได้ขวานทองขวานเงินแล้วก็ขวาน
ตัวเองกลับบ้านเพราะเค้าเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์
อะไรที่ไม่ใช่ของตัวเองไม่อยากได้อืมนะค
แต่กับอีกคนนึงใช่มั้ยผู้ชายคนที่ 2 นะมี
ความอยากได้มาก
นะอยากได้มากๆเราบอกว่าโลภอืมนะตัวเองมี
ขวานหนึ่งใช่มั้ยอยากได้ขวานทองนะเทวดา
เอาขวานทองมาใช่ของฉันปรากฏว่าตัวเอง
เนี่ยโลภเป็นคนไม่ดีไม่ซื่อสัตย์ขวานทอง
ก็เลยหายไปจากมือเลยเทวดาก็หายไปด้วยไม่
ช่วยแล้วเห็นมั้ออ๋อก็คือคนที่อ่าไม่ซื่อ
สัตย์อ่าอยากได้ของคนอื่นเนี่ยก็คือเทวดา
ก็ไม่ช่วยก็เป็นคนไม่ดีใช่มั้ยครูชิใช่
ค่ะเทวดาก็บอกว่าโออันเนี้ยไม่ซื่อสัตย์
นะอยากได้ของที่ไม่ใช่ของเรา
อเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยพอนิทานแบบเนี้ยเล่าแบบ
ของเด็กๆอ่ะบางทีเด็กๆอ่ะไม่เข้าใจใช่
มั้ยเรามีปากกาเพื่อนก็มีปากกาแต่ของ
เพื่อนเนี่ยสวยมากกว่าเราบางทีเห็นแล้วก็
อยากจะได้ไงแต่เด็กบางคนก็ไม่รู้นะก็
อื้อหืออยากได้ปากกาสีชมพูแบบคูบีปากกา
คูชิไม่สวย
อืมแล้วพอครูบีเอาปากกาวางไว้อ่าครูบีไป
เข้าห้องน้ำอืกลับมาเอ้าปากาสีชมพูหายไป
ไหนทำไมมีแต่ปากกาสีเขียวอืครูชิเห็น
ปากกาสีชมพูของครูบีมั้ยเอไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
ไม่เราไม่เอาไปนะนักเรียนเห็นมั้ยคะเรา
ไม่ได้เอาไปเรียนเห็นปากกาสีชมพูมั้ยคะอ
ครูชิไม่เห็นหรอไม่เห็นไม่เห็นไม่เห็นเลย
อืก็วางไว้อยู่ตรงนี้นะ
อืแต่จริงๆครูชิเอาไปใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าอยาก
ได้แต่พอเด็กๆเนี่ยฟังนิทานเรื่องนี้แล้ว
ของอะไรไม่ใช่ของเราอืไม่เอาไม่อยากได้นะ
นะอันนี้เป็นคดีใช่ไม่ต้องไปเอาของคนอื่น
ใช่มั้ยบางทีเด็กๆฟังนิทานเนี่ยก็จะไม่
ไม่ขโมยอ้าบางทีเนี่ยอยากได้ก็ต้องขโมย
เหมือนครูชิใช่มั้ยขโมยปากกาเพื่อนเพราะ
ว่าอยากได้ก็เป็นคนไม่ดีแล้วนะอืมใช่เด็ก
ๆก็จะเข้าใจนะว่าแบบนี้เรียกว่าคนดีแบบ
นี้เรียกว่าคนไม่ดีแล้วคุณอยากเป็นคนดี
ที่เทวดาก็รักใช่มั้ยเทวดาก็รักเทวดาก็
ให้ขวานทองขวานเงินหรือว่าอยากเป็นคนไม่
ดีอืแล้วเทวดาก็ไม่ช่วยเทวดาไม่สนใจค่ะอื
นะอันนี้เทวดาก็ไม่สนใจไม่ช่วยก็ไม่มี
อะไรเลยนะขวานที่โยนทิ้งไปในแม่น้ำก็ไม่
ได้กลับมาคืนใช่มั้ยอ่าใช่ค่ะครูบีเห็นมะ
อันเนี้ยก็เป็นว่าครูชิเเนี่ยฟังตั้งแต่
เด็กๆอืแล้วแล้วครูชิก็เป็นคนดีใช่มั้ยคะ
ดีค่ะก็ตอนเนี้ยโตแล้วก็ยิ่งเข้าใจว่าตอน
เด็กๆเนี่ยทำไมครูเนี่ยชอบเล่านิทานอื
เพราะว่าเวลาเราฟังนิทานเนี่ยเราจะเข้าใจ
อืมากกว่าที่เวลาที่ครูชิเนี่ยไปเอาของ
เพื่อนแล้วครูบอกว่าเอ๊อันนี้ไม่ใช่ของ
เราอย่าไปเอานะคะมันไม่ดีมันไม่รู้ไม่ดี
ยังไงอืแต่เวลา
ฟใช่มยเวลาเราฟังเป็นนิทานเนี่ยมันเข้าใจ
ง่ายแล้วก็มันสนุกไงครูชิมันเหมือนเป็น
เรื่องอ่าที่เราฟังๆังๆังแล้วครูบีก็ชอบ
ฟังก่อนนอนนะบางที
เนี่ยหลับครูบีก็ชอบให้คุณพ่อเล่านิทาน
ให้ฟังเหมือนกันนะคะอืครูทิถึงบอกนะเมื่อ
เอ่อนิทานเรื่องที่แล้วเราคุยเรื่องเอ่อ
ยายกับตาใช่มั้ยนิทานไทยเรื่องนี้ก็
เกี่ยวกับคนตัดฟืนกับเทวดาที่อยู่ในต้น
ไม้นะคะใช่นะคะอ่าก็ผู้ชายที่ตัดฟืนเห็น
มั้ยเป็นคนดีมากนะคะอือนี่เลยเทวดาก็เลย
ให้ควานทองไปเลยทั้งเขาบอกไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
เห็นมั้ยคะอ่าเราก็ดูผู้ชายคนนี้เป็นคนดี
เราก็กอปปี้ได้นะอ่าแต่ผู้ชายอีกคนคนนึง
เนี่ยไม่ซื่อสัตย์เป็นคนไม่ดีเราก็ไม่
ต้องไปทำตามนะคะอืออ๋อเด็กๆก็เลยแบบเาก็
จะฟังนิทานแล้วก็ออเข้าใจมากๆอืเราก็จะ
ค่อยๆเปลี่ยนนะก็จะรู้ว่าอะไรที่เรียกว่า
เป็นคนดีอะไรที่เรียกว่าคนไม่ดีและเด็กๆ
หลายๆคนอยากให้คนรักนะคะก็ต้องเป็นเด็กดี
ค่ะครูก็จะพูดบ่อยๆนะอยากให้คนรักเราเรา
ก็ต้องเป็นเด็กดีอืนะโอแปลว่าครูชิเเนี่ย
ตั้งแต่เด็กๆได้ฟังนิทานบ่อยๆนะแล้วนิทาน
จริงๆมีเยอะมากนะครูชิก็อาจจะมีหลายๆ
เรื่องถ้าเรามีโอกาสเราก็อาจจะเอานิทาน
อีกเรื่องนึงมาเล่าอีกก็ได้นะได้ค่ะครูบี
เพราะว่าเราก็จะสัญญากันนะว่าเราก็จะมา
เล่าเรื่องนิธานนานที่เราบอกว่าเป็นนิทาน
แบบไทยๆนะมีมีการ
เอ่อคือเทวดาในในประเทศไทยที่บอกไงเทวดา
ที่ให้ฝนเทวดาสายฟ้าเทวดาที่แบบเป็นพายุอ
นะเทวดาที่ที่ดูแลป่าดูแลต้นไม้อืนะค
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคนไทยเวลาจะไปทำอะไรที่
ที่แม่นน้ำที่ต้นไม้เข้าป่า
หรือเราก็จะมีแบบมีมีการแบบขอโทษนะมีการ
ขออนุญาต
อ่าขออนุญาตเข้าไปในป่านะคะอาจจะไปทำอะไร
ไม่ดีในป่าใช่มั้ยก็ต้องขอโทษด้วยค่ะก็จะ
เห็นทั้ง 2 แบบเลยเนาะรูปภาพเมื่อกี้ถ้า
เทวดาไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีแฟชั่นแบบนี้นะฮะเห็น
มั้ยอ่าอันนี้เราก็จะรู้เลยว่าเป็นเทวดา
ไทยเห็นมั้ยครูชิแล้วพอครูบีเปิดอีกรูป
นึงครูชิก็บอกว่าอ้าวอันนี้เทวดาฝรั่ง
เทำไมครูชิถึงรู้ว่าเป็นเทวดาฝรั่งคะก็
เทวถ้าเป็นเทวดาไทยอ่ะเทวดาไทยจะเทวดาไทย
จะไม่มีปีก
ไงเทวดาไทยจะไม่มีปีกค่ะอเทวดาไทยอ่ะจะ
เหาะได้อืมไม่ต้องมีปีกนะคะใช่อ่าอันนี้
เด็กๆก็เลยยิ่งชอบบางทีเนี่ยเราไปที่ร้าน
หนังสือใช่มั้ยูชิแล้วก็คุณพ่อคุณแม่อาจ
จะไปซื้อหนังสือนิทานแล้วตอนนี้เนี่ย High
เทคโนโลีค่ะภาพสวยอ่ามีรูปเป็นการ์ตูน
เห็นมั้ยนิทานแต่ว่ารูปภาพเนี่ยสีสวยแล้ว
ก็เป็นการ์ตูนเอ้าเทวเทวดาฝรั่งมีปีกอ้า
เทวดาไทยเนี่ยเหาะได้เหมือนร์ม
ออเราก็จะแบบว่าเอออันนี้ก็จะเหมือนกับ
เข้าใจนะเข้าใจแล้วก็รู้ว่าอ๋ออันนี้
เนี่ยเป็นแบบของไทยอันนี้แบบของเอ่อของ
ฝรั่งใช่เพราะว่าเด็กๆไทยตอนนี้ก็ฟัง
นิทานแบบอีสบนิทานแบบไทยด้วยแบบบ้านนิทาน
บ้านๆแบบคนไทยเลยนะคะก็มีทั้ง 2 แบบนะแต่
ก็ถ้าอ่าบางคนเนี่ยก็อาจจะชอบอ่านไงูชิมี
หนังสือนิทานแล้วก็อ่านอเด็กๆก็ชอบนะมี
ภาษาไทยภาษาอังกฤษอ่าใช่ค่ะนะแล้วก็เวลา
ที่นักเรียนไปวัดเนี่ยเนี่ยอันนี้คือ
เทวดาอันนี้เทวดาพระจันทร์เห็นมั้ยอืมอัน
นี้เทวดาพระอาทิตย์เห็นมั้ยอยู่ที่ฝาผนัง
ของของวัดไทยอืนะอยู่บนก็จะเป็นภาพใช่
เป็นภาพอันนี้ก็เป็นแบบอันนี้เป็นแบบไทย
นะอ่าเทวดาแบบไทยนะถ้านักเรียนมาเที่ยว
ประเทศไทยอ่าไปไหว้พระนะไปเที่ยววัดนวัด
โพธิ์วัดอรุณเนี่ยก็จะเห็นภาพวาดนะนั่น
แหละค่ะเทวดานะเหมือนในรูปทีู่ชิให้ดูเลย
เนาะอ่ะวันนี้ก็ได้ฟังนิทานเกี่ยวกับ
เทวดาที่เอ่อดูแลต้นไม้เนาะูชิกับคนตัด
ฟื้นแล้วก็มีขวานนะคะอ่าตัดฝืนตอนนี้ได้
ทั้ง 3 ขวานเลยขวานไม้ขวานเงินขวานทองอ่า
อันนี้คือคนดีนะคะวันนี้เราก็หมดเวลาแล้ว
ค่ะต้องลานักเรียนไปแล้วงั้นเราก็ต้องลา
นักเรียนกันไปก่อนค่ะครูชิแล้วก็ครูบีนะ
คะก็ต้องลานักเรียนไปตอนนี้นะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ